ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เดี๋ยวขอครูหญิง Share  screen กันนะคะ
อยู่ไหนคะอนุญาติ
ทรูนะคะนักเรียนสักครู่แปลว่ารอนิดหน่อย
นะคะฝันดี
[เพลง]
ชายรูปแรกรูปร่างเดี๋ยวขอทำครูใหญ่ๆก่อน
นะคะเดี๋ยวนักเรียนไม่เห็นเราขอต่อให้
หน้าเราใหญ่ๆใช่ไหมใส่ค่ะครูเองเอกขยับ
ได้กูไอ้ขวดอ่ะ V เลื่อนเนี่ย
นิวเนี่ยจะแพร่ไป 2 รอบแล้วคุยค่ะไม่ได้
คุย The เจ็บเจ็บซี่เนี่ยมีแผลเห็นนะ
อันเนี้ยๆอ่ะนี่แล้วค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋
ค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะหูสีส้มวันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันพฤหัสบดีวันพฤหัสบดีที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
พฤหัสบดีที่ 9
กันอะไรคะ
ปีพตอะไรคะ 2,000 บาท
ปีคศอะไรคะ 2,000
22 หูยาวมากนะคะ
ชายครูเอ๋ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วอันนี้เวลา
บ่าย3โมง 21 นาทีนค่ะ
15:00 น 21 นาทีนใช่ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋สบายดีนะคะสบายดีมากินข้าวอิ่มแล้ว
โว้ยแล้วนักเรียนของเราสบายดีไหมคะครูเอ๋
นักเรียนพยักหน้าทุกคนสบายดี
น้องมีนักเรียนกี่คนนะคะครูเอ๋
13 คน
ชายค่ะเรามีนักเรียน
คุณโรเบิร์ตคุณ John อเมริกาคุณ John
สวีเดนคุณ Black  Tea  is คุณแตฮีคุณ
ปวีณาคุณลิซ่าคุณ Cash คุณโอ
คุณทาดาชิ
ราชิคุณสาระอุ่นคริสทีน
คุณเขา
ฟิล์มสาวคนมีผู้หญิงเก่งมากเลยผู้หญิงจำ
ได้
ถ้าครูหญิงจะไม่ได้คุยตีผู้หญิงหายนัก
เรียน
นักเรียนจะร้องไห้นะคะครูหญิงจำไม่ได้
ไลน์มาหา
พาได้ที่หัวเราะ
คุณธาดาจี้วันนี้ค่ะครูเอ๋วันนี้ผู้หญิง
มีคำถามเหรอคะ
มีไม่มีคำถามสิคะครูเอ๋ก็มีคำถามทุกวัน
เออเมื่อก่อนกูเอ๋มีคำถามมีคำถามผู้หญิง
เฮ้ยตอนนี้ครูหญิงเอาคืนทุกวันนี้คำถามนะ
คะใช่ค่ะมีคำถามแล้วก็มีรูป
ไปให้ครูเอ๋เนี่ยใช้ตาม
จะทำอะไรคะดู
นะดูดูหนัง
สายค่ะดูรูปค่ะแล้วก็ค่อยมีคำถามเอาให้
คุยเห็นดูผู้หญิงถามไก่ค่ะนักตบ
ใส่ค่ะนักเรียนตอบให้นักเรียนดูแล้วฟัง
ไหมสั่งใช้ค่ะดูกับฟังสมัยนักเรียนมีหูนะ
คะนักเรียนก็ตาดูหูฟัง
ใช่ดื่มกาแฟโอเคโอเคค่ะมาดูรูปแรกค่ะครู
เอ๋โรคที่ 1 รูปแรก
อุ้ยอะไรครับครูเอ๋
น่ากลัวมั้ยอ่ะ
คืออะไรอ่ะโอ้โหโอ๊ย
ตัวเอกก็คิดหน้าผากแต่เฮ้ยก็ถูกแล้วนี่ไง
ตื่นเต้นไว้คู๋ตื่นเต้นเวลาครูเอ๋เอ๋เวลา
ครูเห็นใช่ไหมคะเห็นเห็นนิดหน่อย
ชิดมากๆและเรียนคิดอะไร
สองแสนสามท้อง
ไม่ใช่ค่ะหน้าผากถูกแล้วแต่ว่า a คะอัน
นี้อะไรคะเนี่ยผู้หญิงถามจะไม่ใช่ค่ะถาม
ครูเอ๋ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงขาวก็ a  rod คิ้วค่ะหิวนี่อะไร
ครับครูเอ๋ขนคิ้วค่ะลูกเอ๋มีขนคิ้วเท่า
ไหร่คะเว้ย
ขอโทษ The  Wings แกล้งปุ๊บ
[เพลง]
เดี๋ยวนะกูเอกโกรธจนซูไม่เอาน่าคุยเลยนะ
ใครจะนับได้คะ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8 มี
ใครนับขนคิ้วไหมคะได้มีไหมมีค่ะคุณเอ๋รู้
ไม่รู้ขนคิ้วมีกี่เส้นนี้หาไม่รู้ใช่ค่ะ
รู้กะครูเอ๋แต่ผู้หญิงแกล้งครูเอ๋นะคะให้
ครู S ตกใจอ่ะหิวคิ้วของเราเนี่ย
รูปต่อไปค่ะคุณเอ๋ผู้ชายคนนี้นี้นะคะคน
นี้เอาอะไรเนี่ย
หาคนนี้ก็เป็นผู้ชายผู้ชายเขาทำอะไรก็หิว
อยู่คะครูเอ๋เขาใช้คิ้วทำอะไรขอโทษค่ะ
ทำนะ
ทำไมกูหญิงถามว่ามีคิ้วมีขนคิ้วกี่เส้น
เราแบบ
หน้าเขาเหมือนสงสัยยักษ์คิวมั้ยชายค่ะผู้
ชายเนี่ยยักคิ้วจะเข้ายักคิ้วข้างเดียว
กูทำได้ไหม
ได้อยู่นะเก่งวิ่งไม่ได้นะคะไม่ได้มั้ย
เออจริงๆเวลาครูเอกคิดอะไรน่ะโอเคโอเคฮือ
ครูเอ๋ได้
แต่ถ้า
อยู่ได้อยู่นะโอเคนะคะ
สองข้างก็ได้
ใจว่ะ Puss ชายผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยเหมือนครู
เอ๋ต่อมีรูหญิงถามว่ามีขนคิ้วขนคิ้วเนี่ย
กี่เส้นผู้ชายแล้วเหรอ
เห็นไหมงดจะให้ผู้ชายแล้วก็ครูเอ๋เนี่ย
ไม่ต้องพูดยักคิ้วครูหญิงก็เข้าใจว่าอ่ะ
อ่ะ
คิดอะไร
เห็นไหมอ่ะเฮ้อแต่คุณก็ทำไม่ได้นะคะนัก
เรียน
นักเรียนได้ไหม
ใครใช่กูเอกก็ได้นะผู้ชายอ่า
อยากขิวยักคิ้วนั้นไม่ไหวค่ะเหนื่อยมีอีก
ค่ะนอกจากคิ้วแล้วก็นักเรียนยักคิ้วได้
ไหมอ่ะนักเรียนได้ค่ะเวลานักเรียนฟังครู
หินพูดแล้วก็ฟังครูหญิงถามแล้วเดียวหรอก
นะฮะ
ทำไมผู้หญิงตามอาจจะยาคิวแต่ว่าจะส่งถ้า
ว่างแล้ว
หือ
ทำอย่างนี้ผู้หญิงมีรูปอันนี้มั้ยไม่มี
ลืม
หืออันนี้กูเอกขมวดคิ้วทำไมกูเอไม่เข้าใจ
อะไรทำไมขมวดคิ้วไม่เข้าใจภาษาไทย
ครูเอ๋เป็นคนไทยขอครูเอ๋ไม่เข้าใจภาษาไทย
ครูหญิงผู้หญิงพูดอะไรคุยก็ได้แบบหาขมวด
คิ้ว
ขมวดคิ้ว
ผู้หญิงลืมนะคะบทคิ้วนะคะอ่ะต่อไปมีอีก
อะไรคะมีรีค่ะรูปอะไรคะครูเอกคิดว่ารูป
นี้ครูหญิงอย่างให้ครูเอ๋ดูอะไรโหเดี๋ยว
นะมีคิ้วค่ะมีตา
วิตาสวยจังเลยมีขนตา
อ่านี่นะคะขนตาขนตานี้เมื่อมีขนตาอุ้ยคน
ตาสวย
อะไรคะ
ก็ผิดต้องขมวดคิ้วนะฮะ
เดี๋ยวให้ดูให้ดูให้ดูนะ
คุณมี
แต่ว่ารูปรูปที่พี่ให้ดูเนี่ยเขาใกล้ๆไง
ก็เลยมองเห็นคนตาชัด OK ได้ได้เห็นไหมคะ
เอาเห็นแล้วเคยคู๋ขนตากูแอบแบบนี้จะอยู่
ใกล้เลยใกล้แล้ว
น่ากลัวมาก
ตั้งแต่
ใกล้เห็น
รอยสูงห้วยทรวงเหอะ
ตกใจตกใจ
ใช่ค่ะนักเรียนมถ้าเราเรียนถลึงตาเลยเหรอ
มึง
ตกใจนะคะอยู่ใกล้ๆแล้วเห็นเยอะๆไกลๆดี
กว่านะคะใครค่ะตา screw เอ๋ค่ะเห็นแล้ว
ค่ะตาเรามาดูว่าตาทำอะไร
กูเอ๋คะในรูปผู้หญิงทำอะไรคะเขาทำตาอะไร
นะหลิวตะหลิวที่จ๊ะก็แค่หยิบหรอไม่กูยัง
ไม่ได้ของที่ตัวเองพูดผู้หญิงคุณขำที่กู
เอทำตาเวรทำแบบไม่เป็น
เดี๋ยวทำอะไรยิ้มๆแต่ผู้หญิงในรูปสิครับ
แบบ
เออทำไม่เป็นนี่ขยิบตา
อย่างเงี้ยใช่ๆใครหยิบข้างเดียวกับคุณเอ๋
ดู
แลไอ้บาสตัวว่า
กูไอ้เฮ้ย
เห็นหน้าตัวเองยิ้มเลยใช่ไหมยิ้มถ้าพิมพ์
แล้วมัน
กูเอ๋ใครหยิบตาไม่เป็นนำน้ำสายยูขยิบตา
เนี่ยต้องหนึ่งข้างนะคะ 1 ข้าง
ครูเอ๋คะคนไทยผู้หญิงไทยแหละขยิบตาเหรอ
โอเคไหมได้ไหมไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่เรียบร้อย
ใช่ไหมไม่ดี
หือ
202 บางทีโอเคมึงคุณแม่ตี๋ไม่ได้ทรายไม่
ได้แต่ตอนนี้มันทีโอเคใส่สัตว์ดิบตาแบบ
บอกนะกูแต่อย่าบอกเอาใช่ๆอามีสองคำดีกู
หญิงมีคำว่าหลิวตากับขยิบตาไม่เหมือนกัน
หรอหรือว่าเหมือนกันคะ R ขยิบตาเนี่ย
เหมือนกับผู้หญิงผู้หญิงคู๋จะพูดพูดกับ
ผู้หญิงแต่ว่าไม่พูดตรงๆๆๆไม่ให้ครูฟ้า
รู้อาติดตังกุย
ครูเอกครูเอ๋อ่าเดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้ดื่มกาแฟนะ
เดี๋ยวกาแฟกาแฟโอเคโอเค
ก็แบบข้นๆๆ
จริงๆไม่ได้ไปดื่มกาแฟแดกแกล้งครูฟ้าคู่
ฟ้าก็จะจบแฟนที่ไหนกาแฟที่ไหนครูฟ้าก็อ่า
ไม่อยากให้ครูฟ้าไปหรือว่าแกล้งแล้วก็
ขยิบตานะตัวเองอ่าเราอา
หลิวตาล่ะคะ
หลิวตาเนี่ยเป็นเวลาผู้ชายมาหาผู้ชายชาย
ผู้ชาย
แล้วก็เห็นผู้หญิงสวยก็จะ
ปิ้งอ่าหยิบตายเนี่ยสองครั้งตึก
แต่นี้ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงไทยหรือว่าผู้ชายไทย
ก็ไม่ค่อยทำแล้วหลิวตาไม่ทำเร็วตา 8 ใคร
หยิบถึงตาโอเคนะคะมันผู้หญิงกับครูเอ๋ป่ะ
พรุ่งนี้เลยหญิงอ่าโอเคโอเคเข้าใจตามไม่
โอเค
ค่ะแต่ถ้าหัตถ์ทั้งสองข้างแล้วคะอย่างนี้
ทั้งสองข้างแล้วเรียกไข่ขยิบตาไหมไม่
เรียกขยิบตาเรียกอย่ากระพริบตา
เมื่อผู้หญิงขึ้นไปอันบนนิดนึงได้ไหม
เมื่อกี้เราคุยกันนักเรียนอาจจะงงก็เรา
พูดว่าอันนี้นะคะคือกระทะผู้หญิงกับครู
เอ๋ชนะแล้วก็มีครูฟ้าอ่ะครูผู้หญิง
ครูเอ๋ครูฟ้า
ถ้า 2 คนคิดไปดื่มกาแฟไม่บอกครูฟ้าเราก็
เงินโอเคนะหญิงแล้วก็ตึ๊ง
ๆ
สองคนคิด
เดี๋ยวแกล้งกูฟ้าจริงๆไม่ไปดื่มกาแฟแล้ว
จะบอกหญิงหญิงเดี๋ยวเราไปดื่มกาแฟกัน 2
คนเนาะได้ๆได้โอเคอ่ะอ่า
ฟ้าได้ยินฟ้าก็คิดไปกาแฟบอกไม่ไปไม่ไปไม่
ให้ต่อไปนกรักๆ
แรงนะคะเป็นพูดเล่นน่ะค่ะไม่ได้ไปหรือว่า
ไปสามคนโอเคนะคะก็ขยิบตาก็จะรู้ว่าแกล้ง
นะอ่าเปล่าแต่ถ้าอันนี้เนี่ยทั้งตาทั้ง
สองข้างอันนี้กระพริบตาในเวลาบางครั้งมี
ลมมีลมแล้วก็แบบกะพริบตา
จ่ายค่ะนี่มีอีกมีค่ะครูเอ๋อะไรคะจมูกค่ะ
ฝากจมูกใช่ไหมสระหมู่แต่นักเรียนเคยฟัง
แล้วสมุดยังไม่ได้ดมใช่ไหมกลิ่น
หอมหรือว่าเหม็นแต่ว่า
เข้าใจค่ะแต่ว่าอันนี้อ่ะกูอ่ะคะอันนี้
เขาก็ใช้จมูกเหมือนกันเด็กผู้ชาย
กำลังทำอะไรคะกำลังหอมแก้ม
มิตรนี้คือแก้มนะคะหอมแกงแม่เนาะใช่ค่ะ
หอมแก้มคุณแม่
ครูเอ๋หอมแก้มคุณแม่คะคุณแม่จะไม่เอา
คนไทยไม่ค่อยหอมแก้มคุณพ่อคุณแม่เนาะเข้า
แต่คุณพ่อคุณแม่จะหอมแก้มเราโง่แบบเราไม่
หอมแก้มคุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้เราฟังคนบางคนก็
ชอบหอมแก้ม
เวลาเด็กๆอ่ะพ่อก็ชอบขอมแก้ม
แล้วถ้ากูชาย
เอาสีอะไรดีอ่ะผู้ชายกับผู้หญิง
ที่เป็นแฟนกันหอมแก้มกันไหม
ก็ได้เนาะได้ง้อแฟนใช่ไหมแกนหอมแก้มได้
แต่คุณพ่อคุณแม่เห็นไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ไม่ให้คุณพ่อคุณแม่เห็นสองคนโอเคอ่ะที่
BTS ไม่ได้
ได้อะไรล่ะที่ห้างไปซื้อเสื้อมานี้เสื้อ
นะคะไปเดินเดินๆแล้วก็ซื้อเสื้อแล้วก็หอม
แก้มไม่ได้ที่บ้านได้ไหมบ้านมีกี่คนท้อ
ต้องอยู่แค่ 2 คนหรอสองคนโอเค
ดีนะทักหญิงผู้ชายอายุเท่าไหร่ด้วยอ่าตี
สามสิบสามสิบปีแล้วโตแล้วขอโอเคสองคนหอม
แก้มแต่หอมแก้มนะนี่อีกแล้วครูเอ๋
อะไรคะมีจมูกมีลิมิต
มีฟันก็มี
ลิ้นนิดหน่อยนิลลิ้นนะคะเล่นนิดหน่อยมาดู
ว่าริมฝีปากฟันลิ้นทำอะไรบ้างงูเก๋
ๆในรูปผู้หญิงทำอะไรอยู่คะผิวปากค่ะครู
เอ๋ผิวปาดได้ไหม
ไม่ได้
รู้หญิงก็ไม่ได้แต่คนไทยเนี่ยไม่ทำเนาะ
มันหายไม่ได้พิมพ์เปล่าแบบนี้ไหมไม่ใช้
นิ้วใส่มั้ยคนไทยเนี่ยรู้ใช้ป่าก็ครูหญิง
ทำไม่ได้อาเหมทำไม่ได้อะไรนะ
with  Two
ประเทศไทยมากๆผู้ชายนะผู้ชายจะผิวปากผู้
หญิงไม่ค่อยนิดหน่อยมีผู้หญิงนิดหน่อยที่
ผิวปากได้นะคะอะไรค่ะอ่าอ่ะแล้วรูปนี้ที่
ผู้หญิงทำอะไรคะใช้ปากกัดแตงโมตายตัดแตง
โมครูเอ๋กัดไหม
กัดอะไร
ผู้หญิง
อะไร
คู๋
กัดอะไรคะกัดแตงโมผัดแตงโมไหมเกย์ถามครู
เอกกัดแตงโมใหม่กลับค่ะถ้าคุยหญิงถาม
กันมั้ยคะเอกคิดว่ากูหญิงเดินมาคุยกัดผู้
หญิงแล้วก็เก่งกัดครูหญิงไหมมี
ญาติ
ไปกาดไหมกาดร้องเราต้องเป็นขึ้นหมาเป็น
หมาน้องหมาหมา
กัดน่ะหมาเนี่ยกัดนะคะฮ่าๆมาเนี่ยกัดนะกู
เอกผู้หญิงไม่ใช่หมาแล้วนะไม่กัดใช่ไหม
เวลาตอกแต่งโมแล้วหรอกัดแตงโมเข้าไปในปาก
แล้วเราทำอะไรคะเขียวค่ะงั้นเดี๋ยว
เขียวแตงโม
มีรูปอีกค่ะครูเอ๋อ่า
นี่ฮะลิ้นใช่ไหมคะในรูปเนี่ยผู้หญิงเนี่ย
แลบลิ้นแลบลิ้นฉันแลบลิ้นใส่เขาจริงๆแลบ
ลิ้นเราก็ทำได้เนาะถ้ากูหญิงไม่ชอบครูเอ๋
วิ่งออกไป
มีเด็กผู้หญิงเราอายุ 30 ขึ้นไปแล้วไม่
บอกต้องเด็กๆหรอคะต้องบอก 3
3 ขวบ 4 ขวบกับเด็กๆถ้าไม่ชอบคือแลบลิ้น
และแต่ถ้าไม่สบายไม่สบายไป
โรงพยาบาล
ค่ะโรงพยาบาลบางที่คุณหมอก็ให้อ้าปาก
อ้าปากแล้วก็
แลบลิ้นเอา
กดลิ้นเราก็ดูนะดูที่คอฝาก
บอกก็จะบอกแล้วลิ้นหน่อยอ้าปากอ้าปากอ่ะ
ไม่เห็น
แลบลิ้นหลังค่ะอ่ะ
นะแต่ว่าในรูปนี้เนี่ยเขาใช้ลิ้นทำอะไร
อยู่คะครูเอ๋เรียไอติมแหมเวลาครูเองกิน
ไอติมนี้ครูเอ๋เรียไหมหรือว่าเก๋เองกัด
เลยฉันให้คุณก็กลับเหมือนกัน
แต่เท่าไหร่โอกาสเจอหรอจ่ายแล้วก็จริงๆ
Where เด็กๆคุยกันเลียค่ะแต่โดนตี
ไหวๆก็ได้กัด
เนาะ
เอ๋เอ๋รู้ปนี้เนี่ยเขากำลังทำอะไรกันอยู่
คะกำลังทำอาหาร
ซ้ายแล้วผู้ชายทำอะไรตัดอาหารให้ผู้หญิง
ชิมนาเวลาชิมแล้วก็ใช้ลิ้นใช่ไหมลิ้น
เนี่ยชิม
ไก่ไม่อร่อยก็ทำใหม่นะๆอ่ะใส่ไข่ใส่เวทย์
เวลาครูเอทำอาหารครูเอ๋เนี่ยชิมไหม
บางทีชิมบางทีไม่ชิม
อร่อยก็กินได้ไม่อร่อยก็กินได้แม่สามีบอก
โอเคกินได้พอโอเคโอเคทำอาหารสามีกินนะครู
เอกก็เดินเดินเดินซื้ออาหารตัวเองร้อง
ครูเอทำไม่กินไม่กิน
โอเคชิมแล้วไม่อร่อยๆสามีกิน
กินเข้าใจค่ะผู้หญิงเคยเหมือนสามีคู๋
ต่อหาครูเอ๋คะรูปนี้เนี่ยเพลงคิดว่าคุณ
ให้ดูอะไรคะดูไหล่ค่ะตรงไหนคะไหล่ไหล่นะ
คะไหล่ก็ตรงนี้อันนี้บ่ายเนื้อหาอันนี้
ไหล่บ่าหลับแล้วก็ตรงนี้หลังตรงนี้อ่ะ
ข้างหลังตรงนี้สมัครค่ะตรงนี้สันหลัง
กระดูกสันหลัง
ปูโหเอาอะไรอีกกูเองเก่งมากเลยค่ะตรงนี้
อะไรคะขอคอ
ต้องมีอะไรคะกันกระดูกสันหลังกระดูกขึ้น
ไปที่คอค่ะ
ตรงนี้มีประเทศก็
มี 7 จะต้องคอเนี่ยมี 7 ข้ออย่างโอเคค่ะ
แตะผู้หญิงอยากได้แค่นี้ค่ะหัวไหล่ล่ะคะ
หลายๆไหล่ใช่แล้วอุ้ยไม่รู้ได้ยังไงคะว่า
รูปต่อไปผู้หญิงจะให้ดูของดี
ดูแล้วนะคะเอกคะผู้ชายใน 4 คำ 5 อะไรยัต
ไหล่ยักไหล่ผู้หญิงเนี่ยยักไหล่ใส่ครูเอ๋
ได้ไหมไม่ได้
ทำไมเป็นเด็ก
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงต้องเป็นเต่า
ผู้ a พูดก่อนผู้หญิงผู้หญิงคะกินแครอท
เยอะๆ
ไม่กินทำไมต้องกินน่ะอย่ามายักษ์ไหลนะ
ทำไมยักษ์เลยมั้ยเนี่ยใช่ไม่ไม่น่ารักไม่
เรียบร้อยเป็นเด็กไม่ดี
ไม่ได้เหรอแล้วครูเอ๋ยักไหล่ใส่ครูหญิง
ได้ไหม
ได้
ทำไมเป็นผู้ใหญ่
หอมสุดใครค่ะก็ไม่ได้เค้าไม่ได้
คืนถ้าคุยยักไหล่แล้วบอกว่าหญิงห้ามยัก
ไหล่ก็ไม่ได้นะกูเองไม่ยักไหล่ให้ครูหญิง
คุยผู้หญิงก็ไม่ยักไหล่ให้ครูเอ๋นะคะถ้า
ขาย
ไม่ดีแต่ก็โอเคผู้ใหญ่ผู้หญิงเด็กแล้วยัก
ไหล่ไม่ดีมากๆ
บายค่ะคนไทยเนี่ยถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศไทย
แล้วเพื่อนถามกินอะไรดี
อะไรก็ได้เจอเพื่อนจะคิดนักเรียนทำไม่
โอเคเพื่อนจะแบบทำไมต้องยักไหล่แต่นัก
เรียนเนี่ยไม่คิดอะไร
แต่ถ้าเป็นปัจจุบันคนไทยก็ดูทีวีดูหนัง
ฮอลลีวู๊ดมากๆก็โอเคแต่คนแก่จะอีคืออะไร
ใช่แต่ถ้าเป็นเพื่อนน้องอาร์ม
อายุ 3  4 คนนี้ก็อายุ 30 อ่ะจะโอเค
โอเคอยากได้ไม่ทำใช่ๆอ่ะคิดว่ายังไม่หมด
นะครับตัวเองมีอีกอะโอ้อะไรคะครูเอ๋มือ
ค่ะเบอร์เราดูว่าเบื่อมือทำอะไรขอเขาทำ
อะไรคะรูปนี้ปรบมือค่ะตบมือครูเอ๋เอ๋เก่ง
มากแต่คนไทยบางคนผู้ตบมือ
ได้ปรบมือโอเคตบมือโอเคโอเค a ได้
คู๋ตบมือยังไงคะ
ทั้งหมดตบก็คือหรือว่าปรบมือ
ไม่ได้ยินสู่มันตัด
ใช่ค่ะค่ะ
ในรูปผู้หญิงเอาใช้มือถือว่าใช้นิ้วใช้
เล็บทำอะไรอยู่ครับครูเอ๋เก่า
เก่าเก่าหัว
เก่านะเวลาเรานะ
คู๋เหมือนลิงนะถ้านักเรียนดูดีๆเดี๋ยวก็
เก่าเดี๋ยวก็เก่าเดี๋ยวก็เก่าแล้วเรียน
บอกครูหญิงครูเอกลูกฟ้าเหมือนเหม่งเก่า
บ่อยๆๆๆ
ไม่ได้ขันแต่เก่าอะไรหรออะไรล่ะกำลังที
เราแบบเฮ้ยอะไรอ่ะเราก็เกาหัวแล้วคู๋
วินคำเลยเห็นไหมเกาแขนไอ้เก้าน้องฟิวเข้า
เกมเอาจมูกเก่าไม่รู้จะเอาอะไรทำใหญ่
เดี๋ยวเจ้าอยู่
ฮ่าๆคนอื่นเค้าก็สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงผู้เอก
คู่ฟ้าในเก่ากับ
ประเทศไทยมันร้อนแล้วนักเรียน
อามีอีกครั้งครูเอ๋ขอในรูปนี้เนี่ยเขา
กำลังทำอะไรคะใช้มือต่อยค่ะได้ค่ะเขากำ
หมัดใช่ไหมกำหมัดแล้วก็ปล่อย
ฮือจานอีกไม่ดีกี่นะไม่ดีไม่ดีไหมเอาต่อย
ต่อยไม่ดีหรอคะไม่ดีค่ะไม่ดีอ่า
อันนี้ดีกว่าค่ะ
ตบหน้า
คุณดีกว่าอย่างไรอ๋อไม่ดีเหมือนกันนะ
โอ๊ยตายอ้ะแล้วรูปนี้ผู้หญิงทำอะไรคะครู
เอ๋
แค่คิดแบบคนไทย
ฉันอยู่นี่
ไปใส่เหมือนบกมือมั้ยโบกมืออยู่นี่อยู่
นี่
[เพลง]
บ๊ายบายก็ได้หรือว่าอยู่ที่นี่ได้หมดจ่าย
ค่ะยกรถยกมือชายกมลละถ้ามีนิ้วผู้หญิงไม่
ได้เอามานะคะแล้วทำแบบนี้
ได้ยินไหม
ไม่ได้อยู่แล้ว
กูเจ็บดีดนิ้วดีดนิ้ว
ดีดได้ค่ะแต่ว่าที่ว่านักเรียนไม่ได้ยิน
ซูมมันตัดเสียง
ดีดนิ้วนะแต่ผู้หญิงดิบนิวส์เซเว่นเอ๋
ไม่ได้
นะคะไม่ได้อา
สานักเรียนอันนี้ก็คือ
หมดเวลาแล้วอันนี้ก็เป็นท่าทาง
ท่าทางที่เราทำใช่ไหมใช้คิ้วใช้ตาใช้จมูก
ปากอันนี้นะคะครูเอ๋ไหล่ยะในมือก็นิ้ว
หน้าขาแต่ว่าวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋
ทำไมเวลาไปเร็วๆ
ทรายโรงเรียนปรบมือเลยหมดเวลาแล้วต้อง
แล้วเย้ปรบหรือ
ทำไมดีใจจะได้เบรคแล้วก็เรียนต่อ
ค่ะเดี๋ยวเจอกันนะคะสวัสดีค่ะโบกมือบ๊าย
บาย